au conseil municipal de tours ce match
par micros interposés entre l'actuelle
et l'ancienne majorité
au menu un budget qui met l'accent sur
le social mais aussi le dossier de la
cuisine centrale
huit mille repas quotidiens aux élèves
aux écoliers de la ville le maire
emmanuel denis stop le projet de son
prédécesseur pour la construction d'un
nouveau bâtiment
lucas chopin les discussions
s'enchaînent à la mairie de tours
aujourd'hui on vote pour le premier
budget de la majorité des manuels denis
et la part belle est faite à l'action
sociale 2.5 millions d'euros y sont
consacrés dont 400 milles pour le ccas
la mairie parle d'un budget offensif
c'était un budget qui prend la mesure de
la crise que nous traversons ça c'est un
premier sujet et c'est un budget aussi
qui s'inscrit dans la durée et dans des
réponses structurelles pour réduire sur
le territoire de notre ville les
inégalités qui sont trop nombreuses dans
l'opposition on salue le geste mais on
regrette certains investissements
parallèle et une déclaration je les dis
une déclaration d'intention c'est très
bien c'est une majorité de gauche donc
elle a plutôt intérêt renvendiqué social
en fait dans les faits vous avez une
augmentation pour l'action sociale qui
est l'équivalent de la prime vélo qui
est allé aux plus aisés de tours parmi
les autres sujets débattus aujourd'hui
celui de la cuisine centrale de tours la
précédente majorité la voulait mutualisé
avec celle du chu l'ancien maire
christophe bouchet y voyait une façon de
réaliser des économies
ce projet a été abandonné mais c'est une
immense bêtise
une immense bêtise est un immense gâchis
c'est que ça permettait mécaniquement de
déporter la dette de cette cuisine vers
le gip vers l'ensemble chu est de la
ville ce qui permettait de faire des
économies sur le budget strict de la
ville finalement la nouvelle cuisine
centrale sera exclusivement dédié aux
8000 élèves tourangeau une dépense
amplement justifiée selon la majorité
c'est un équipement structurant qui va
alimenter toutes les écoles de la ville
pendant les trente prochaines années je
pense que ça mérite qu'on y mette un peu
d'argent au démarrage pour ce soit un
équipement qui répondent aux nouveaux
enjeux de l'alimentation est aujourd'hui
l'équipement qu'on propose ne coûte pas
plus cher que ce qui aurait été fait
avec une mutualisation avec l'hôpital
l'équipe municipale devrait décider
d'ici quelques jours de l'emplacement
précis de la future cuisine dans un
quartier de tours nord